have you seen the group chat you're
doing it again tonight
no please that's my mom's Remembrance
Day I just want to forget about it huh
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll do it
cannot go for more than 90 seconds am I
clear what happens after 90 seconds
don't want to stay
light the candle to open the door
blow it out to close it
put your hand on it
now say
talk to me
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me
what does the hand feel like
so amazing I could see and feel
everything on the other side
so my mom she was trying to reach out
I'm here
still been saying stuff you've been
saying stuff
what if we open the door but we didn't
shut it
oh my God they followed us
they're not gonna stop
you're never gonna stop
I like you
[Music]
talk to me